az én sztorim az röviden az hogy
fényképészként nagyon-nagyon közeli
kapcsolatot ápoltunk három négy öt másik
személlyel akik szintén fényképészek
voltak és mit csinál egy fényképész
hétköznap ül a számítógép előtt és utó
munkázik és ez az utó munkázás egy idő
után már átvált egy olyan rutinnál hogy
hogy mellette podcastet tudok hallgatni
sat többi sat többi tehát a mai napig
ezért vagyok én ekkora podcast függő
mint hallgató is mert mert nagyon sok az
az időm amikor tudok hgat
eg adott ponton valamikor ott 2 x évben
nem tudom mikor volt a
podcastünk azt mondtuk hogy hát miért
nem vesszük fel ezeket a
beszélgetéset így indult el az első
podcastünk ann